la tienda local abre a las 9 horas su
estacionamiento tiene 6 filas y en cada
una de ellas se pueden estacionar 7
automóviles
cada automóvil tiene cuatro llantas
cuántos automóviles se pueden estacionar
en total para que nosotros podamos hacer
eso vamos a releer nuestro planteamiento
y nos están dando datos de que la tienda
abre a las nueve horas realmente eso a
nosotros no nos causa mayor conflicto de
hecho tampoco nos interesa saber que
cada automóvil tiene cuatro llantas así
es que ambas informaciones las
eliminaremos lo que si nos interesa es
saber que el estacionamiento tiene seis
filas
seis filas y que en cada fila pueden
estacionarse siete automóviles
siete automóviles tenemos las filas y
los automóviles cuantos automóviles se
podrán estacionar allí nosotros lo que
haremos es multiplicar 6 por 7
o lo que es lo mismo
sumar 6 veces el número 7
así es que colocar en anaranjado 123
éste quedó raro
3 4 5 6 y lo que haremos es sumarlos
como les decía una multiplicación lo que
implica es la suma de ese mismo número
cuántas veces lo estamos multiplicando
es decir seis veces el 7 1 2 3 4 5 6
vamos a sumar entonces 7 7 es igual a 14
más 7 21 más 7 28 más 7 35 7 42 nosotros
podemos decir entonces
se pueden estacionar 42 automóviles
los móviles
en ese estacionamiento no me crees pues
hice un diagrama aquí para que ustedes
lo puedan ver y entonces podemos
considerar ésta como las filas y
contaremos 1 2 3 4 5 6 filas recuerdan
se acuerdan cuántos autos que habían en
cada una de estas filas 7 vamos a hacer
1 2 3 4 5 6 7 autos así es que tenemos 7
14 21 28 35 y 42 y así lo desean lo
pueden contar ustedes uno por uno para
asegurarse que nuestro resultado es
correcto